[Music]
this is going to create community
under collectibility in a way we've
never seen
[Applause]
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
may 5th before you watch this video may
5th i'm dropping it
huge project please please pay attention
to all my socials all my channels may
5th i've got a secret project i'm
dropping it with a complete focus
on making sure a that everybody's part
of this community my og
social media content youtube gets to
really win
wait do you see the way i structured
this this isn't just the art there's a
lot of
access and community and a lot of
[ __ ] thoughtfulness months and months
in the making may 5th be ready
have your metamask filled with as much
aetherium as you can afford
we're doing it
[Music]
garyvee how are you man thanks for
coming i'm well maddie thank you so much
for having me on the show
awesome so like the nft industry is
blowing up everything's going crazy
um i want to get into it but before that
i always like to start with the story
the you know the culture like where did
you come from a lot of people know your
story where did you come from how did it
started how did you get here
yeah not to belabor a story i'd like to
tell a lot so you know russia
you know soviet immigrant came to the
u.s
queens dover edison new jersey very east
coast kid
grew up very entrepreneurial very pop
culture
collectible you know work ethic kid
lemonade stands
you know um shoveling snow washing cars
but then
very into comic books toys um
star wars wrestling gi joe transformers
thundercats gobots
smurfs snorks get along gang max
headroom
alf punky brewster and
and then really made a living as a
teenager selling
sports cards and then also being an
arbitrage kid right buy something at a
closeout
for a dollar go to a flea market sell
for four
got dragged to my dad's liquor store
took a lot of those skills and became
very passionate knowledgeable about the
wine business
had an incredible 15-year career um
in the wine business building one of the
e-commerce
uh one of the big e-commerce wine retail
stores
in america launched winelibrary.com in
1997
and and really built
a big business for my dad um
and really really am proud of that
and then kind of in my early to mid 30s
decided to
get into web 2.0 very heavily so
you know i launched you know for me nfts
is really 3.0
1.0 was 95.96 when like oh this internet
thing's gonna be great
um myspace friendster youtube
then twitter facebook became 2.0 for me
where i became
garyvee the wine guy not just a kid that
built a big business
um in the y business through e-commerce
and then
i and that's how i feel about nfts it's
a 3.0 for me i feel like this is
um uh you know a new
a new era for me you know it's funny i
never thought of myself as a speaker an
author a personality
i was 30 i was past my 30th birthday
maddie when i made my first piece of
internet content
so the whole gallery wasn't it was
episode one of wine library tv
nice what what
what's interesting about this as i'm
doodling away here
in the midst of my project obviously
there's investor gary
and i'll invest in platforms and an art
but creator gary these doodles i'm
making
this is much more natural to me than
personality gary i've been a doodler
and a drawer and a kind of like a
character
creator my whole life um obviously
i did it a ton as a kid as i became a
liquor store owner
there was less opportunity for it but
something i don't talk a lot about is
when i was 14-18 one of the biggest
reasons my dad
valued me was because i made all the
signs for the store on paper
and sharpie and would literally make
the signs like kendall jackson
chardonnay 8.99 crossout
6.99 but i was creative it wasn't just
the words
i would draw a little wine glass i would
draw a turkey for thanksgiving
by the beaujolais and i would use
ironically sharpies
which is why i think i'm good at it
right now because i made
tens of thousands of signs from my dad's
liquor store
and that's you know it's fun because web
2.0 brought out
something in me that i didn't know nfts
is bringing out something in me that i
know better about myself but the
world knows very little and unless
you're a
hardcore garyvee nut and watched every
dailyvee and
and weekly bee and see it in little
moments where i draw
in the fall in the the dew of a window
or if i'm in meetings
um so uh that's my story
cool man that's very rich i can't i
didn't know the
doodling culture was just so rich in the
history of it
but i can't imagine how big the nft aha
moment was for you because
it looks like the industry was created
for the collectors the investors the
flippers the people that went to school
and
you know bought and sold things and
loved arbitrage first of all what is it
about
arbitrage or flipping something and
making a ten dollar profit in between
that you love so much because
that's something i have as well and i
just can't explain it um and then
secondly
it was the thrill it's the thrill of do
you see something other people's don't
you know i've you know i i was raised in
a manner where
you know money was a source of roof over
the head food
you know i'm you know i think you know
this about me probably because
we've especially lately really enjoyed
interacting with each other like i'm not
in it for the rolex or the corvette or
it just you know i don't like stuff but
i love the game
and like does my brain see something and
you know
i keep going back to garage sales more
than sports cards let me tell you why
maddie
nfts are going to be a lot of eye of the
beholder art
even even when there's things like
pokemon they'll probably be multiple
projects
different you know and i was great at
garage saleing
pre-ebay in the 90s because i would see
a mork and mindy or happy days thing
and i could see it there was no value
yet
ebay hadn't come out yet but i just knew
the pop culture reference of
it you know the abort i was big on board
games for example
you know like the those would be lunch
boxes i remember buying a ton of lunch
boxes
i ended up being very right about metal
lunch boxes ended up being good
you know i just understood nostalgia
you know and and so i like storytelling
and i love
all this stuff and yeah i mean you're
right for me
this is crazy i mean this is not a joke
maddie
the second i had my aha moment so the
ahas started
in the winter of 19. you know
it's funny in 2016 aaron battalion
really educated me in a hotel room at
south by southwest about ethereum and i
bought ethereum
nice and i really believed it i was like
okay this bitcoin thing because i bought
bitcoin two years earlier
that that may be the thing but i
remember thinking but it might not be
you know like who knows which currency
wins obviously it did go on to kind of
win
to win but i remember thinking
even if it does this ethereum thing's
really interesting because
it's not just it's not current and i'm
not really a financier i actually don't
really like
i didn't go into the ico altcoin
universe
because i don't like it not that i don't
think it's important not i don't think
it's profound not that i
don't think it's interesting i have
never bought a yen
to trade it for a euro i've never been
interested in that
but buying a trajectory and flipping it
buying a sports you know buying a
trading in all my sports cards for comic
books and toys
in late high school that was a huge
arbitrage i was this baseball card
dealer for seven years
i started going to card shows and i'm
like i don't like the vibe
it feels like there's less people here i
don't like the vibe
and then i'm like this comic book
culture is blowing up comic-con you know
like i'm like
so i you know so i traded in all my
sports cards for comics and
toys and i ended up being right by the
way cards collapsed a year later and
comics and toys went up and so you know
i'm good at that game i feel it i feel
the masses
and so the the the it always
has been in the back of my mind i've
been aware-ish
the fall and winter i started smelling
some stuff
you know i spoke to roham in july about
nba top shot
i was like that's interesting you know
like and so i was just like there's
something brewing
and then i had the luxury of december
and january last week in december first
week of january to be off because i was
still navigating vayner
x through the troubles of covet you know
people i think a lot of people don't
realize that i'm the active
ceo of a 1500 person global marketing
organization
and i mean active like i'm more
operational than most ceos to begin with
let alone what i think people perceive
which is i'm gary vee and a mascot
and other people run the business i run
the business
and so i didn't have the time to dig in
but then i did in december
and the aha moment was like january
third fourth fifth like it was like oh
[ __ ] you know and then i started was any
any specific product or any any like
moment you remember
i remember kevin rose the
you know incredible internet cultural
guy
founder of dig.com um
hit me up and he's i must either said
something or he saw something or he just
ran
i don't remember i'll go look back at my
ims
um but um
he's like what do you think about this
crypto punks thing
and i was like and i was like i'm not
sure about that
like i didn't really know about it um
and that was i think in december uh and
i just started
reading everything and five hours later
i'm like [ __ ]
this is like the og aetherium project
oh what's here this and
721 and 20. i'm like this is [ __ ] rad
digging digging digging
and then and then a month later when i
was like
oh [ __ ] this is a hundred this is gonna
happen
i started thinking and then i started
spending a few more minutes on it i was
like
okay here's my gut feeling this is gonna
happen like the internet happened in 95.
but oh [ __ ] top shot's doing well
these punks are going to pop off
everybody's going to start an nft
project in the summer i remember saying
that it's in the spring instead
and and there's probably going to be a
huge bubble like icos
and like internet stocks in 2000 so but
i want to play
because i don't want to just sit and
think for three years
so let me buy punks because i feel like
this is something that makes me
understand like i under and you know
this one of our first interactions
you know on social on a dm or something
was that where i was like how do you
i know you've been around this stuff but
i'm telling you know like it was like
fun right like
i really i think now let me take this
moment before i forget because i get
into a flow
i think you're you're just a very good
voice for this space i see your tweets
coming through and i think
you know i think we i think probably the
way we've connected probably intuitively
quickly with each other is
i think we see a lot of things similarly
is my intuition based at least the one
you're tweeting like
i think that the space is going to be
all time
but that um many many many of the
current projects this exact second
are incredibly vulnerable to being
terrible investments
call it beanie babies call it pets.com
whatever you want to call it
that doesn't take away from the macro
nfp moment
definitely but it definitely um
it definitely uh uh is concerning
um but i am for example the project i'm
building
the way i'm thinking about the smart
contracts the access the community the
things i'm doing
i'm thinking about this as a 45-year
project
so even if that was my question next
there's all these nft projects
you said you know they may kind of pop
off they may go to nothing to maintain
to dust so what's the longevity plan
what's
what's the x factor that keeps them
relevant what do you think i think
they're not doing right i think that
it's the underlying smart contract i
think there'll be too much supply of the
art
but i think the logic underneath it the
utility the community the access that ip
and
influencers and celebrities and humans
and
craftsmen and influencers and humans
the underlying value they bring
underneath
their token has incredible long-term
ramifications and i think you'll see in
the next 18 months people get
dramatically
more educated and the projects that are
going to come out are going to be far
more thoughtful
i think nfts will come to mean a lot
more than what we see right now
and i think it's you know nfp is it's
a technology layer right it's like it's
a token first
it's not an art piece it's not a
collector it's the token first
it's and that token whether that's a
membership to a club or that's a vip
access rope or if that's a ticket
what's cool what's cool is that becomes
um uh give me one second i apologize
um that becomes a secondary derivative
in a very powerful way for example
sporting events tickets or concert
tickets right bob dylan's
most famous concert i'm not a bob dylan
enthusiast nor uh
you know understander of his collectible
market
however i have a very good feeling that
a ticket stub from one of his most
iconic or most iconic conferences
currently sells on ebay for a certain
price
i'm fascinated that most of those
tickets are gone
there it's very you know it's hard to
connect you know what i'm looking for
maddie
that in 22 years i meet someone new
and i look at their public wallet which
will be as common as looking up
someone on google or their instagram
account and i'm going to make a
connection point with a new friend or
acquaintance
and be like oh my god we were both in
wimbledon in 2025.
yeah you know like just like i don't
think people understand the social
currency
the human psychology this is going to
digitalize
things that people have been doing
forever i love when people like this is
so stupid i'm like you know what else is
stupid
people that buy 900 little elephants
from all around the world
and have it displayed in their [ __ ]
living room why is that people look like
people collect backpacks matchboxes
like you know what else is [ __ ]
stupid that you bought keychains from
every
country you ever went to that's [ __ ]
stupid comma
no it's not that's why hundreds of
thousands of [ __ ] people do it
um here's the difference here's the
difference that's right we're magnets
but here's the difference
if there's only 913 rare magnet
from new zealand's great rugby today
right now
the 913 people that own that have no
connection to each other
this is going to create community under
collectibility
in a way we've never seen why does
everybody go to comic-con and love each
other immediately why do i feel warm if
i go to a star trek convention
because these are people that enjoy the
same thing that i do
well that feeling is now going to be on
scale authentically
non
no fraud in ledger form and all the
technologies are going to be built on
top of it to display that
to create closed communities around it
hasn't even started
do you understand that i'm sitting here
with obsession of thinking everything
i'm going to do for next 50 years to
make sure that everybody who buys any of
my tokens when i drop it
not only makes a fortune as an
investment
but has a lifetime of memories
i think that's the key right it's a
longevity plan it's the creators that
are seeing these nfts as not just an art
piece but a
thing to continuously add value to and i
think a couple of really good examples
stand out is when justin blau dropped
his art pieces and then
you could use that nft as a token to
enter his club in decentraland and it
was like this
club with unreleased music and you know
this was a special thing when he said
that i was like oh crap i want one now
right and also mark cuban dropping nfts
and saying hey i'll do a 30 second shout
out
powerful you get mark cuban to talk
about what you want by buying this nft
um there was something for tens of
thousands of dollars and he can
continuously add value to those nfts
that's the that's the key
for 10 20 30 50 years that's the biggest
key the
nft has unlimited utility correct
and no one gets that in the mini and
organizations that try to bring more
value to the audience
than the short-term economics for
themselves maddie
i have no clue what my launch is going
to do i really don't
i don't have a [ __ ] clue i'm going to
dutch auction i'm even scared for
manipulation
so i'm dutch watching right you know
like i really have no clue i'm going to
do some buy now for my original fans
like
i'm gonna i don't know what's gonna
happen but let me make you a promise on
one of the more important podcasts in
this community in my opinion
when i know what happened when it's all
said and done that kind of initial
if that's a dollar or if it's a billion
dollars i'm going to spend my
life making sure that that's going to be
a multiplier for every person that touch
it instead of what i'm seeing right now
where a lot of humans take a quick bag
and go to sleep
there are [ __ ] humans that are famous
right now who just made
hundreds of thousands and millions of
dollars selling an nft
and have literally moved on
that's the problem right think that it
was a good deal
for humans on the other side bought
a digital asset of them by the way
usually which is ridiculous and
that's it and celebrating it and i
you know i'm even i'm i'm just listening
to you know i'm doing quick
i'm so [ __ ] busy but like every
second i get nine minutes to go into a
room on clubhouse
people are celebrating this and i'm like
what about the people that are sitting
with the bag
i'm very glad that you millionaire have
made more money
and listen i'm not anti-entrepreneurship
so let's let there be no confusion with
my tone right now
go make 47 trillion if you [ __ ] did
the things that led to that
you did that so i'm about that but i'm
worried that somebody bought
a picture of someone for a hundred
thousand dollars
because i already know once every person
has a picture of them
in the next two years that the supply
and demand
of that asset is gonna not be to a
hundred thousand it's probably gonna be
ninety seven dollars
maddie especially yeah there's like
thousands of celebrities
sports players there's not a celebrity
on earth or influencer on earth
on earth right now that hasn't talked to
their management or their brains
whoever that is whether that's
themselves or people around them
are about nfts there's not one that
exists that hasn't done it
yeah it's huge man but you know what the
cool thing is gary and this is a cool
like an nft
special is that you can sell nfts and
then people can forget about the project
and then three years later they can dig
it back up again and suddenly those nfts
have value so these well
sold right dude i haven't bought yeah
they're so i
love you for saying that like i'm
desperately desperately desperately
trying to get my ass together and spend
four hours on moon cats
right like i haven't bought any i think
somebody get i always loved saying
everything because i was i'm scared that
people like you
you know i believe yeah somebody gifted
me one
my brother aj gave him one of my wallets
to send one so that means i own one i've
never bought one
but that was cool as [ __ ] i was i've
been busy the last
month so i didn't really like it seems
maybe you can correct me here
because again you know just too much
information too much going on my life
but it seems like it was this like
lost project quote-unquote and
it seems like it's very early 2007 i
mean 17 18. it sounds like 18 if i
remember
um and it's cool i'm excited about it
i'm definitely definitely definitely
hoping that i get my [ __ ] together and
be able to go buy some
interesting man yeah it's crazy i
definitely like the 17
18 projects i definitely like them i
don't know how many there are
i don't i'm wondering if there's any
other lost ones i think so this is an
interesting thing i wanted to make some
sort of a timeline and someone
made one actually of like the projects
and their launches on blockchain like
when they actually hit blockchain
because then we can have a timeline as
to when all of these things
have to look at it can you i think there
is a website i'll send it to you after
yeah
i will please i really really want to
see that so anyway i like that i
i like those projects and to your point
i'll give an example
if i gary vaynerchuk was
in 2007 saw nfts the exact same way
i would have launched this project the
difference is i would have had 4
000 people in the wine world give a [ __ ]
right but then as my next 14 years
kind of progressed you know like when i
started dailyvee and had it kind of five
years ago another
let's i would call it another pop
somebody would have been like oh [ __ ]
i'm going back and buying those those
are only
point three e and then as my career
progressed and i think to your point
like one of my favorite this is why i
tell people to buy [ __ ] they like
it's like music see art
think collectible too that's fine and
money like that's fine i'm never going
to poo poo that i hate when people like
this should just be our like
that's not fair you get to tell people
that they're not allowed
that's not fair but i'm so excited about
somebody
finding a project they like .01 eth
or wax or flow you know i'm not i'm
agnostic
it's all going to end up in one place
and can you imagine you're like oh these
are just fresh [ __ ] logos
you buy for that and then nine years
later that person becomes virgil abloh
or banksy and it pops
there's gonna be some [ __ ] cool [ __ ]
yeah
which is why i think a very good
strategy for anybody who's listening
is buy [ __ ] that speaks to you because
if it speaks to you it may speak to
others
and eventually this is going to be
everywhere and it's not just gonna be
certain voices
whales or people with audiences that are
gonna it's
like the masses will take over which
projects matter
and i think i think right now is the
most riskiest because right now people
are listening to those influences
they're listening to people with an
audience
whether whether we want them to listen
or not and that's why it's so risky and
i like how you clarify that you were
given a moon
moon cat not bought one because that's
important
i don't know if you've watched how i've
moved the last two months i'm petrified
to say anything because i'm not
i don't know you know i've literally
i've talked about
punks right i've talked about loving
uh loving top shot overall very
concerned about the
because that's the world i really know
individual sports cards so i know
i just mentioned for the first time
mooncats i've said here i've not said
another thing
outside of this what i'm saying right
now about the project
because i know if i did
that right now everyone's so on tilt
that even though i have
literally and i think you know this in
every
single interview podcast
said 99 are gonna fail be careful
the macro is unbelievable all time the
micro
even that anytime i even begin to
flirt with a statement about something
chill you're manipulating the martial
you know you're in a really shitty spot
if you have an audience
i can't even speak things that i think i
like i'm also scared in the other
direction for example art blocks right
people love like
i don't like art like art i like
characters
i like you know i don't like jackson
pollock i like
andy warhol right like i like a culture
so i'm even scared to like say things
i'm not as in love with that people are
really hot on
because i'm just scared that somebody
may take that the wrong way and then
like i couldn't live with myself if the
next day the thing's down 25
to people there's so much thoughtfulness
and i think people are
not being thoughtful and so i'm
trying to be thoughtful because i want
to
look back at how i navigated these
unprecedented times with pride and
so that's that has a lot to do with the
way i'm thinking about things maddie
yeah you know what the scary thing and
the scary factor that we have to take
into account and sometimes we can't do
anything about it is
blockchain man blockchain allows money
to transfer like this
if someone has a decision that they want
to make you tweet something or i tweet
something or anyone tweet something that
says a
word boom you can click a button and you
can buy one money transfers that quickly
it's not a credit card
and a lot of this money is is is kind of
money that people have made and 10 next
over the last
you know six months and so there's a
community here that are playing with
house money in the sense so there's so
much extra money they have
right that they've made and then there's
a community here with hard-earned cash
trying to get involved
correct one is splurging to experiment
one is trying to invest and trying to
take it seriously and trying to be very
diplomatic
but it's difficult because it's such a
there's so much there's so much
intersect of everything crazy right now
another question and this kind of puts
me into the next question is how do you
navigate through the fear and a bit of
uncertainty and i think a lot of new
creators coming to this space it's
a bit unoverwhelming because i remember
putting out some tweets and saying you
know it's a good time to build your
social media it's a good time to do this
and then a good time to do that but
there's so much happening how do you
do you have any advice for anyone that
are a bit fearful of the rapid change of
everything and how do they
take part in this if it's moving too
fast right
i want to define how you give me a
scenario with fear because i
i i'm obsessed with the concept of fear
i think it's a perspective vulnerability
that
doesn't need to be there so for example
fear
uh let me give you how i heard the
question and clarify for me
another example if you don't mind
you want to invest in something but
there's so much going on
you're not sure if you're blockchain and
then you learn that the media could like
disappear
like every day right play
with money you can afford to lose
when things are in this moment if
there's a
person listening or watching right now
that is putting money into nfts
that if it goes to zero would
disproportionately change their life
they are making a monstrous catastrophic
mistake
during these innovative times that are
very wild wild west
very pirate ship just very murky waters
very exciting i mean this is you know
for you know for
i'm sure for you and i this is exciting
there's a thrill to hunt like there's a
lot
not a penny well i put into nft
affect if it all goes to zero affect my
responsibilities
and i think that everybody should do
that and whether that's a million
dollars for the incredibly well-off and
accomplished
or whether that's 13.19 cents
play with money that you can lose
buy things that you like
and if you're going to invest because
you don't like it but you think it's
gonna make money
do 30 50 hours
of homework each project
each 30 to 50 hours of homework uh so i
think you can get the overall sense of
nfts yeah
to your point of each project pattern
recognition it's so much easier now like
moon cats took me an hour and three
minutes
right versus three days right like you
gotta you know once you get the
foundations down
that's true that's right you start
understanding yeah yeah you start to see
what's important especially once you
have some experience and you see some
money come back some money
go up or whatever um good
good uh good advice though man some some
what some skills
do you think that would help people in
this new age because uh it's moving so
fast man it's it's
everything's interesting i just feel
like as a creator or as an investor
as a collector as a i'm going to say i'm
going to say as a
create creator because as an investor
we and i know it's a hard question to
ask you because i'm not sure if you are
a creator
you know listen one of the things do you
rock you mind getting a couple of pieces
i'd love to show
i'll let maddie when are you planning on
uh
airing this manny me uh
you're doing audio so we won't have to
show this video until after
so i'll be doing an audio and video is
that cool yes can you blur this out
yeah cool so like these things that i'm
drawing
right you know and obviously i've been
putting some of these on social so it's
not even that big of a deal anyway
nonetheless um you don't need to blur it
out i just realized i forgot about
cherry
yeah positive thank you though um
i uh have a huge
recommendation for creators one of the
things i realized is in 95 i saw the
internet i wasn't a tech kid
i launched a website immediately i had
to get my hands dirty
in 2006 i saw social media personal
brand
i had never aspired to be an author an
actor
a personality never gave a speech in my
life what did i do jumped right in and
became a creator
nfts like i can understand it
intellectually from an investment and a
businessman standpoint
if i'm going to be really of it i got i
got ink on my hands
right so i'm i'm a creator
and i have a huge recommendation make
what you love
and make your project about
the audience if you can it's so
simple make don't listen to somebody
that says
oh characters do better than images or
colors do better than black and white or
or
other ip remixes are better than your
[ __ ] all that if you're creative
create now almost everything i've done
people told me i was wrong
gary you can't be a public speaker if
you curse you know how much i was told
that
right gary people like lighting and
audio my first thousand episodes of wine
library tv i wasn't even miked
poor drock had a fight for like three
months to even get me miked
i film [ __ ] with the wrong lighting all
the time i raccoon eyes i look like [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ]
i make what i want no second take know
this but you know what i mean
and it's worked for me because it's me
by the way if you're the reverse
lighting's got to be on point do what 16
takes
do you because there is no rules from a
creative standpoint
b and more importantly in my opinion
think about the other person think about
the person who's going to buy it now
for example if you're like [ __ ] you gary
i'm not even worried about economics
this
i'm an artist and i want the person to
enjoy it great
good news doesn't sound like you have to
overthink
your contracts right you basically
at its most basic level does the person
get the physical
it are you even making a physical are
you just doing digital
sounds like all you have to do is figure
out your royalty like right
but if you're worried about them do you
want your royalty to be one percent
instead of the 10
or do you want to do 20 because you
don't think the 10
pseudo standard that's emerging is right
i'm going to do a bunch of my tokens
that are going to give a percentage of
charity
like you know do things on the other
side
and you can run the gamut for me i think
of the art as
the last piece even though i know a lot
of my characters are gonna speak to
people and some are gonna buy
just for the character a lot of the
real unveiling which is not the imaging
but like everything i'm actually doing
that will be here soon enough i'm aiming
officially to be
oh wait i'm waiting i'm aiming for may
5th i may not hit it a lot of tech
building a lot of stuff um but
i'm incredibly excited about
everything i'm doing on that front and
i'm spending pretty much
all my time on the contract part
so just do you and do you and do them
right yeah yeah i think it's a that last
sentence is really important because
it's like how do you think in my view
and what really
kind of helped me a lot as being an
entrepreneur was to think how much more
value can i give
then take right like how can this value
share be more beneficial for the person
on the other side than it is for me and
when this as soon as i did that and i
started to just continue to give more
value than i got i was like oh wow this
it just makes so much sense i understand
how business continues or long longevity
is continuing and that's why like
projects like yours or projects that
that continue to compound utility to
nfts make so much sense because
they click right it's an ability for us
to continue to do that so for artists
like you said you know can i give a
physical with this how can
someone benefit with my art what can i
do to help them obviously not
doing it to a point of stress but just
keeping it in mind
yes i see it that's what i this is my
life
my life is 51.49 i'm not a hundred zero
i'm not out here trying to be a buddha
i'm a businessman i love it
i love the game it's who i am i'm an
entrepreneur and i'm proud of it
but i think i can give 51 of the value
to the other person
because i know what to do with my 49
that's a good way to put it and i really
like it and i think that
you know when i die that last day
if i know it's happening i'm going to
feel really good because i think i
really have figured out something and
i'm a young man now and i hope to
continue this conversation for 50 years
that there's good ways to do things
that's selfish selfless
works
and to me if you can be 51 selfless and
49
selfish there's something real powerful
there and you clearly
click that click for you somewhere along
the way and for me too
and it has been the message out of my
mouth and i
i it's why business is beautiful to me
there's bad versions of everything
there's [ __ ] teachers there's [ __ ] cops
they're [ __ ]
politicians they're [ __ ] mothers and so
that means they're [ __ ] business men
and women but if you really look
there's such a truth to the marketplace
to the brand
that the brands that win are giving 51
to 49.
true that is true man that is true a
couple last questions
what would your advice be um for i know
this is hard but what would your advice
be for someone with a thousand dollars
compared to someone with a million
dollars in terms of investing for me if
you're a thousand dollars you're
definitely thinking about the lower gas
fee projects right because it's kind of
like devastating to pay
the gas fee on an ethereum price so wax
flow some other right
that's one thing to keep in mind um a
million bucks
i think you go to where we talked about
17 18 projects or
and listen i want to be one of those
guys my biggest hope maddie
honestly is that my project is
referenced
for what is done well in 2022. that's my
big if you ask me a selfish goal
that is actually very selfless is that
mine goes so well
that it stops everyone in their tracks
and says oh wait a minute let's go back
to the batcave we got to think this and
the lab
we got to think through our [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] if we're making a sparkly
version of it
like this we need to like really think
and i think i think if you've got a
million
you're looking at og projects because
they'll always be og
everyone talks about providence well
guess what and documentation and legend
there you go that timeline [ __ ]
matters for example
you said that timeline i'm gonna when
you send it to me and i'm gonna bug you
in an hour if you don't say to me that's
how excited i am
i'll tell you why you're gonna love this
i immediately thought about the first
thing
i said i wonder what the fifth official
ethereum project is
because for me the number five is
everything it's my jam it's why i put
my hand like this in photos interesting
yeah so my mom needed me this sweater i
got a whole thing to it right
anyway i'm literally curious
if there's gonna be you know and i know
some of this is gonna be whoever put
that together there's a lot of hard work
you never there might be a lost project
but i'm immediately gonna look at
whatever is considered to the fifth
project and like probably dig into it
for several hours be like okay i want to
get behind you know
yeah it's really cool so i think if
you've got a million og projects
or if pokemon comes out
in six months which is an incredible ip
if star wars comes out
incredible ip if disney comes out
incredible ip
if marvel comes out incredible ip and
they
do it well this is why i want the 30 to
50 hours
of education you and i will dm each
other or text each other the second one
of those four projects launched is their
real real one
and we'll both chat of like did they do
it well
like do we like it and i may think
pokemon is better than harry potter ip
but if harry potter structures its
economy and smart contract ecosystem
in a dramatically better way than
pokemon did i may actually go
into potter not pokemon got it
got it man i hope pokemon does it right
like that's my i hope pokemon does it
right too
because you know what's interesting gary
please i think um
because we're it's such a a phase where
we're all learning right even these big
ips are learning
if they do do it wrong and then
somewhere along the right uh along the
way one year later they're like oh okay
maybe we should re-release with this
proper strategy i wonder if
because it's going to be a 20 30 50 year
thing now digital assets i wonder if
that first release will become more
important uh or more collectible things
so this is like the whole game right
or less important or you know like or
what was officially there's a lot of
people that are putting out very
very kind of like amateur projects with
good ip right now
and we've seen that through the years
like you know there's been there's i
think people are more concerned
than right what's that brother i think
people are more concerned about being
first
than being proud and let me give you a
comp in sports cards
there are cards that are made that are
not considered the rookie card that are
years earlier than the rookie card
because one of them was done better by a
better company
right right so there's a there's a
company called star
cards that made basketball cards
akimolajon michael jordan
charles barkley patrick ewing carl
malone
john stockton all have cards
made in 83 84 85 86 before flir 86
came out stockton was 88 by the time he
had his
rookie card now that brand star got
[ __ ] up because there was a big
counterfeit issue with it back to
funny haha here we are with the
blockchain right
but also even in when it was less of the
counterfeit issue when i was in the game
in the 90s
they were rare but still not more
important
than the flear and so you know
i could see somebody going with a
company launching through them but then
changing its chain and doing it directly
there's a lot to your point that's about
to happen and i'm excited about it and
i'm excited about it because i've got
30 years of experience 40 years actually
jesus no
no 30 years 30 plus years of experience
around
understanding collectibles how people
work
and i'm uh i'm excited about that
awesome man last question
what is some of your uh because you just
have so much experience and this is like
your place right
collectibility collecting what are some
some key cultural things or
parts of the economy that are important
for people to keep an eye on
so history age and all that sort of
stuff but you know you got some
history age of course but scarcity math
matters
but let me tell you where everybody gets
[ __ ] up maddie people
struggle with demand supply is binary
there are 1 000 of these but they
struggle with demand
you know i i'm very foolish of michael
jordan's rookie card the psa 10. there's
317 of them
sometimes my friends are like gary but
there's 317 of them i'm like yes
but do you know many people want that
card
they're like yeah but there's only 18 of
this one i'm like yes but that's not
michael jordan
so i would tell you the number one thing
i can tell you maddie
that everyone misses and i see it
happening in nft is demand
they you know why they struggle with
demand manny because demand is something
you have to feel
there's no formula to it well there's
going to be some formulas to it for
example
if this it seems like discord culture
for projects is real so
you could go into a discord of a project
you stumble upon and see
four hundred thousand people on that
discord i have a funny feeling a smart
man like he's gonna be like [ __ ]
so there will be some but it's but it's
but it'll never be
real no matter how many people because
there'll be too many people that are not
part of
demand is misunderstood it's my great
gift
it's why i was good at selling wine it's
why i'm good at most things
demand is an emotional intelligence
supply
is a mathematical understanding so the
number one thing that everyone's missing
is how good are you at tasting
smelling feeling hearing
demand which means you're leaning into
emotional intelligence
which most people haven't advanced on
yet
yeah good points man interesting yeah
i i've got a couple of tools that i use
for demand specifically one of them
is going into new discords and just
checking out the new members
consistently for 100
before the project during the project
even two months after the project
are people continuously coming in and
also sales fees for example
how much are selling every day before
during and after
three months later is it still selling
uh and and again you're right man
emotionally and the culture and the
people it's hard to kind of get a sense
of that and i see you jumping into
discord and i think that's what you're
doing
yes but you know what's funny i've never
to your point in kudos to you and i'm
glad you brought it up
i've done less math work
and i think there's a lot of ways to
your point to do math around demand
i've always felt that that's the
commodity
i can always get that information it's
are you
in the dirt in the trenches in the
culture
in it to understand it's coming because
what you're talking about is things you
can see
that have happened what i'm spending all
my time on is knowing tomorrow is going
to be the day that that discord doubles
in size
and by the time you see that post game
i've moved
predicting predicted on
pulse yeah
cool man that requires listening by the
way on the record
i always laugh when everyone's like this
guy's such a [ __ ] loud mouth i'm like
if they understood how much more
listening i do than talking they'd [ __ ]
their [ __ ] pants
awesome man thanks for the chat it has
been an honor i've been waiting for this
for a while but uh your your knowledge
and your shares and your your tips are
always
i i always read them because i know you
come from a heavy collecting background
and this is
at least for the time being a very
collector-heavy space
so again maddie i'm going to say
something else i will believe my history
of success
in nft will be more that i was a great
community builder for 15 years around
gary vee
than that i am a great collector i think
both ingredients are going to mean that
i'm going to the moon
but but and i appreciate you saying that
but i will tell you right now on the
record because i want to see how it
plays out in 15 years
it was my knowledge of how communities
are built because i am
one of the humans on earth that lived
the last 15 years in influencer land
who i would argue has done it as well as
anybody mainly because
i don't have a lot of the things that
work for other people i don't have
shocking beauty i don't have a
television or movie platform to get
awareness everything i've built has been
brick by brick by brick from the dirt
of very niche things starting with
little wine community
to business you know and piece by piece
by piece by piece
entrepreneurship yes yeah and look where
i am in my career right like i
understand there's people that don't
love me because my aggressive
communication that's fine
but i've done it and i think my
understanding of what
it takes to build a community and an
economy of currency
around humanity and people and human
dynamics
and the companies i've invested in like
there's a lot of ingredients
that i understand that i think lends
itself to this space
which is why i'm so deep including my
favorite part about me that i wish more
people did which is
i'm willing to get my hands dirty and
get in
that's the tough part right because
people don't want to do that they want
to just hear some news
read a blog post and then uh yeah make
it an investment
yeah that's right yeah and to me it's
it's also the other thing i'm proud of
and i did it in web 2.0
and i did in the wine business i'm doing
it right this second in the meta
i also like to pay homage to the people
that lay down the foundation
you know when i used to pay homage and
like be respectful and visit people
i wasn't bringing that much as a kid
today
this you're gonna you know you're gonna
get a lot more lessons on your podcast
i'm gonna share this so now i'm in this
incredible play you know i used to
always fear getting older because i was
a whiz kid
it was my identity and i didn't realize
how great this is now i carry a big
stick
so now what now i'm going to be able to
i have the humility
to go you know i don't come into this
space saying okay um and here comes all
the cubans and shimmy like who gives a
[ __ ] about the ogs i'm the reverse
i want to kiss the rings of the og's
and now that i have the platform to be
able to do things that give them
more exposure [ __ ] me i can't wait to be
90 now
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon